obviously we're talking we're tweeting a
lot about the boston dynamics robot
because that [ __ ] was so funny
yeah first of all
the best one was the one at the end that
was like it looked like a
like a chicken hen or something let's
pull it up right now we can watch it
without
music but it's it's um it looks like a
hen like it's like um
it's like a giant steamer with a
balancing act
if you just pull up the frame bro where
yeah like just go like 209
that one that one with the big old ass
just like bouncing up and down like that
damn i hate that [ __ ] dog one
yeah that creeps me out so much why did
they make it like that
i mean you know man isn't it creepy it
is
that that thing that's like gyrating up
and down
that's kind of bad
that thing's going to be sucking your
dick while it's hauling you off to the
amazon gulag bro
that thing's got a giant ass holy huge
ass
oh yeah dude i wonder maybe yeah
killing or something you can't wait
to be able to nail that thing
i i i don't know i kind of hated that
video it's cool
obviously i don't think it's cool i mean
it's
it's why do you think it's cool scary
yeah you know okay here was
here's my uh here's my
next black mirror episode okay okay
uh so boston dynamics robots
become consumer and uh
government assets right and and they
they're part of like a botnet where they
can like share information and [ __ ]
okay all right this is my 2040 black
mirror coming of age movie
okay inch uh starts with a young woman
in her room she's home for the summer
her friends want to go
out they call her up they're like
britney we're all hitting we're all
hitting delores tonight are you coming
she's like no why
i tested positive for chlamydia and now
our house robot won't let me leave
my parents left me here with it and if i
leave it's going to wrap me out
and then jason gets on the phone he's
like dude my boy has an
emp we'll shut it off we'll get you to
the club
she's like oh my god [ __ ] yeah her
friends show up with the emp
they kill the house robot they all get
in their um driverless car and it drives
them to delores
okay and now they're lost when they get
there now they're in line at delores
it seems like the night's gonna go well
okay and she still has chlamydia still
has chlamydia
so she could be actively spreading it
could be
because that's how chlamydia has spread
that's uh coronavirus has me thinking
that that's how all
everything's spread yeah just when
you're someone you just get [ __ ] you
know
she got chlamydia and so she have an
active case of chlamydia and she's
waiting in line at the club when he lied
to the club
and then um they like delores because
it's more underground it's usually got a
human touch but
dolores they got a bouncer bot
and they're okay oh [ __ ] and the bouncer
boss starts going down the line he's
scanning everybody
he gets to brittany and he's like
chlamydia active case chlamydia she's
like what
no i don't have clinton everyone's like
oh you came with a club with chlamydia
she has chlamydia and then a [ __ ]
automated cop car pulls up
six boston dynamics robots come out
they're like you have chlamydia and they
haul our ass off to the chlamydia jail
and story
that's good man what's chlamydia jail
like is that just
are there eight other people with
chlamydia and at once
but everyone's just scratching and
everyone's like damn
everyone's just leaking yeah one guy's
like it's not even fair dude i just have
pink eye
this is conjunctivitis that's that's
chlamydia of the eye that's chlamydia of
the face actually is what they call that
she has chlamydia she has chlamydia what
no
i don't guys chlamydia chlamydia
chlamydia active chlamydia no i don't
know i don't it's like what she is
chlamydia the robot turns herpes he
hasn't
he's like what no everyone starts
getting arrested for stds the std police
are there
no no third
you have an illegal case of scabies
more more and more boston dynamics std
police
start showing up and just [ __ ]
hauling [ __ ] young people off
just just [ __ ] never mind
never mind curable ones gonna make a bad
joke but
curable ones if you have a curable std
we're not shaming you and if you have a
non-care velocity we're not shaming you
either i'm just saying
i thought about a universe where you
know
maybe these robots just are giving a
little too much information
and they just start acting mean about it
you know yeah yeah just start outing us
in public
that's i think that's really funny
honestly the sgtd
the std police
that's human do you imagine going on dp
std whatever stpd yeah yeah
sexually transmitted people department
yes
doesn't mean can you imagine like a like
one of these robots working at foot
locker and it just like says some
[ __ ] slick [ __ ] about you it's like
the left foot
doesn't fit because it's bigger than the
right you're like hold on
[ __ ] is your problem robot what are you
saying
i'm saying i was just making an
observation
i've noticed that the left foot is
slightly larger than the right foot
and your left breast is slightly larger
than your right breast
hey hey hey hey hey
don't look at me like that oh my god
[ __ ] insensitive victoria's secret
robot
hi would you like help with a bra um
yeah sure
i've noticed one of your breasts is
larger than the other hey [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we have lopsided bras on this side of
the store hey what the [ __ ] is your
problem bro
the exact millimeter difference between
your two breasts it's just way too loud
just blaring that [ __ ]
we can add more cushion for the droopy
one for the trippy one
for the droopy for the droopy one for
the true the droopy one
all the robots looking she has a droopy
one she has a droopy one
i don't believe in breast shaming man i
don't believe in
any body shaming you know all breasts
are equal man
you know boobs are sick regardless yeah
you know don't don't let these um don't
let the
don't let the booby by the victoria's
secret make you feel any differently
okay great
these gray sweatpants are no good for
you
[Laughter]
the bulge is non-existent in these pants
let me take you to the little boys
detected it's not detected
huh subject has no penis are you sure
you
aren't a nine-year-old boy no visible
bulge in these pants
would you like to go to the little the
little men's section
this is my [ __ ] bulge alone
anyways
you